uh very quickly i don't want to spend a
lot of time on this but some people
wrote to me again and they said uh what
is going on with the n-word being used
by
failed former president donald trump
this is starting to get really strange i
almost think trump's trying to just
appear to be provocative
trump multiple times now has referred to
nuclear or nuclear depending on your
pronunciation preference as the n-word
and now he did it again at some kind of
event i don't know if this is a
fundraiser or a party or what it is
trump now saying hey everybody went
crazy when i referred to nuclear as the
n-word
take a look we have the greatest nuclear
force in the world you don't want to do
that you know the i call it the n word
okay i said that to a group of people
they said dear word oh he said a
horrible thing i said no the nuclear
words
he said always that horrible thing the n
word
that says no the n word is the nuclear
word the nuclear word is something
that's not supposed to be discussed
you don't talk about it
you don't talk about it
why are people even clapping like it is
completely incoherent what he's saying
and people they're clapping because
trump says you're not supposed to talk
about the nuclear what
about it
a serious nuclear power he's talking
about
okay so
trump now is referencing when he went on
fox news program uh i don't even know
what it's called what's the it's a
program with stuart varney it's called
uh i i don't even know what the show is
called stuart varney's program on fox
business and he played the same kind of
koi game well hope to god you never have
to use it because it would be that would
be the tragedy of all tragedies but if
we didn't have it we couldn't talk but i
listened to him constantly using the
n-word that's the n-word and he's
constantly using it the nuclear word
and we never
talk if we say oh he's a nuclear power
what do you guys think this is about is
this some kind of a dog whistle where
white supreme i'm making this up by the
way guys is this a dog whistle where
trump is signaling to white supremacists
i can't go around using the real n-word
but i'm going to say the n-word and
pretend i'm talking about nuclear but
i'm actually talking about the n-word
is is that is it a dog whistle that only
some people understand is it trump
trying to just be provocative
by using the term n-word even if it has
nothing to do with the actual n-word
i don't know what he's trying to do it's
very very strange one last bonus clip
just about how weird things are that are
going on lately here's trump talking
about when he met matt gates's wife
this was over the weekend i guess at
mar-a-lago it's just all very bizarre i
do remember when they met he came up i
said who the hell is that man
not that i noticed those things but i
said who's that i said matt i don't know
how well you get along but assuming you
get along that's the one for you
and now it's uh you've come a long way
together haven't you it's a great couple
and we appreciate it and we love you
both
and we're with you all the way
real weekend at bernie's vibe starting
to go there at uh at mar-a-lago but very
strange what's this n-word stuff about
guys let me know i really don't
understand it you can find me on twitter
at d pacman this is one of the last
times i'm going to mention this because
we're doing the event in a few days
tuesday
april 19
6 p.m we're doing a town hall event town
hall events are where you get to ask me
questions you get to berate me for
whatever you want to berate me for
it it's wide open this will be streaming
live so if you want to listen to the
town hall it'll be live at 6 p.m on the
pacman live youtube channel that's
youtube.compacmanlive
it won't be on the regular youtube
channel it won't be on facebook it won't
be on twitch it will only be
at youtube.com pacman live tuesday april
19th 6 pm
if you want to call in
then it's going to be via discord at
davidpakman.com
discord if you're not a member
everybody's welcome to call in however
if you do become a member we are going
to have a priority path for you to get
on the air for our paid members
everybody will get an opportunity but
it'll be easier if you're a member and
you can sign up at
joinpackman.com so that's tuesday but
still a full show of stuff coming up for
you today
one of our sponsors is called privacy
privacy is a totally free service that
i've been using for years privacy lets
me create virtual payment cards with one
click and when i use the virtual card
the money is taken out of my bank
account you can create multiple cards
delete them freeze them set a spending
limit on them let's say i'm signing up
for a free trial and it requires a
credit card privacy will autofill a
virtual card number and then after
signing up i can delete that virtual
card so i know i'm not going to be
charged again something really useful
and very practical or let's say i'm
ordering food over the phone but i left
my wallet somewhere i don't have my real
credit card on me i can use a virtual
card on my privacy mobile app but really
the best part is
you're not out there exposing your real
credit card number so you're not as
susceptible to data breaches and
identity theft privacy is a totally free
service and you'll get five bucks to
spend when you go to privacy.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video